merci de nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure si elle est Nouvel
An vous êtes élu de la Seine-Maritime
membre du groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste et coteur d'une
proposition de la pour protéger les
collectivités face à la hausse des prix
de l'énergie on va bien sûr longuement
parler tout à l'heure mais d'abord un
mot sur la prime carburant puisqu'elle
Isabelle born a annoncé hier que le la
ristourne à la pompe serait remplacée
par une prime carburant pour les
travailleurs modestes à partir du 1er
janvier prime de 100 euros ça concerne
10 millions de personnes est-ce que
c'est la bonne mesure pour vous bah
écoutez ça va représenter quoi à peine
plus d'un plein pour les salariés en
question
qui voit la remise de 10 centimes par
litre du gouverne enfin faut pas rouler
beaucoup pour que ça équivalent à 10
centimes par litre parce que moi je suis
dans un département où il y a de
nombreux salariés qui font 20 30 km deux
fois par jour pour aller au boulot et du
coup à peine plus d'un plein sur l'année
ça va pas être vraiment un soutien
considérable et puis je trouve que il y
a beaucoup de salariés avec des revenus
somme c'est assez modeste voir des
classes moyennes qui sont exclues du
dispositif alors que ça pèse très lourd
on le sait moi je sais c'est le montant
qui vous va pas ou c'est le calibrage il
fallait garder des aides pour tout le
monde c'est le montant le calibrage et
puis je pense qu'il y avait d'autres
solutions beaucoup plus efficaces par
exemple nous nous proposons de diminuer
les taxes la TVA par exemple sur les
carburants financer par une taxation sur
les super profits que nous avons proposé
encore lors du PLF récemment parce qu'on
voit bien qu'il y a des grandes
compagnies
pétrolières qui qui s'enrichissent à
l'occasion de cette crise et qu'il
faudrait répartir les richesses
autrement et qu'on pourrait
considérablement diminuer le niveau des
taxes pour que ça bénéficie à l'ensemble
des consommateurs et je pense
particulièrement à ceux qui sont
contraints de prendre leur véhicule pour
aller travailler parce qu'évidemment il
y a des gens qui vivent dans des grandes
métropoles qui ont accès à des
transports collectif elle est transports
publics mais il y a aussi beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas d'autres
solutions que de prendre leur voiture
je pense qu'il y en a beaucoup plus vous
avez dit que le salaire c'était
en dessous de 1300 euros il y a quand
même beaucoup de salariés qui vont
échapper à cette mesure et ça va peser
lourd dans le contexte qu'on connaît les
collectivités sont également touchées
par la hausse des prix de l'énergie vous
êtes coteur d'une proposition de loi qui
vise à protéger ses collectivités de la
hausse de ces prix de l'énergie elle
était examinée hier mais elle a été
rejetée on va voir les temps forts de la
séance avec Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour et on va donc revenir sur cette
proposition de loi du groupe communiste
discuté hier au Sénat dans le cadre de
votre niche elle avait pour but de
permettre à toutes les collectivités de
bénéficier de tarifs réglementés des
prix des énergies dans un contexte
d'explosion des factures elle a été
rejetée oui pourtant votre collègue
Fabien gay qui est défendait votre texte
n'a pas les inné sur les arguments c'est
une idée toute simple qui ne date pas
d'hier a-t-il avancé c'est vrai qu'il y
a encore quelques années toutes les
communes avaient accès aux tarif fixés
par l'État on va voir aujourd'hui
pourquoi c'est plus le cas parmi les
autres arguments en faveur de la mesure
le coû 3 milliards d'euros d'après une
agence indépendante quand les différents
boucliers amortisseurs filets de
sécurité représente 45 milliards d'euros
et ne couvre pas toutes les communes
c'est ce que vous avez rappelé hier dans
votre département la Seine-Maritime
elles sont 86% d'après ce que ce que
vous nous avez dit à ne pas pouvoir y
prétendre mais votre proposition a été
rejetée pour plusieurs raisons la
première parmi les arguments c'est
qu'elle est contraire au droit européen
vous n'autorise un accès au tarif
réglementé que pour les petites communes
de moins de 10 employés et de moins de 2
millions d'euros de recettes pas pour
les autres l'autre argument c'est que
les tarifs réglementés du gaz prennent
fin pour tout le monde l'année prochaine
en juillet 2023 la proposition irait
donc contrôla loi il y a aussi le
problème de la concurrence parce que
seul le fournisseur historique peut
pratiquer des tarifs réglementés et puis
il y a un dernier argument c'est Laurent
saumon le rapporteur de la commission
des affaires économiques qu'il a
exposées on l'écoute
un grand nombre de collectivités ayant
souscrit des offres de marché souvent
via des groupements d'achats de leur
syndicat d'énergie une résiliation
anticipée de ces offres les obligerait
indemniser leur fournisseurs ce qui les
fragiliserait contractuellement et les
pénaliserait financièrement voilà pour
les raisons qui font que la majorité
sénatoriale de droite n'a pas soutenu ce
texte pourtant votre collègue soit bien
gay à tout tenté emporter l'adhésion des
LR écoutez
permettez-moi de citer quelques
il faudra sans doute aller plus loin le
groupe LR vous prie de revenir sur la
suppression des tarifs réglementés un
véritable bouclier ne doit pas consister
à un déversement d'argent public pour
les ménages ou dans l'économie ces
paroles très sages
ne sont ni de Jaurès
ni moi-même elles sont celles du
brillant président au taillot le 12
octobre dernier donc
ça convaincu la majorité sénatoriale par
tous les arguments du groupe communiste
que nous venons de donner au moins
respecter la parole du président rotaïo
voilà pour la touche du mot mais hier
vos collègues de droite ont qualifié
votre proposition de dangereuse pour les
collectivités de fausses bonnes idées
est-ce que vous comprenez leurs
arguments que j'ai exposé un petit peu
plus tôt pas du tout parce que les
collectivités sont très nombreuses à
nous interpeller sur le fait qu'il faut
faire quelque chose et que la MF
l'Association des maires de France a
initié une campagne pour le retour à ses
tarifs réglementés de vente de l'énergie
et que on voit dans un certain nombre de
communes d'émotions adoptées par les
conseils municipaux pour dire il faut
avancer dans ce sens là et donc nous ne
comprenons absolument pas l'attitude de
la majorité sénatoriale hier soir
avec des arguments parce que
ce serait contraire au Droit européen
mais pendant toute la crise sanitaire on
a pris des tas de mesures et
heureusement qui dérogeait complètement
au droit européen les 3% de difficile à
commencer par là on les a oublié avec le
quoi qu'il en coûte et donc il y a
matière et on s'appuie sur des arguments
juridiques qui permettent de déroger on
est dans une situation de crise et donc
il faut y faire face avec des moyens
ambitieux
les tarifs réglement parce que enfin
faut mesurer les augmentations que ça
représente pour les collectivités moi je
travaille sur ce sujet là depuis plus
d'un an parce que j'avais été alerté par
le maire de Oissel dans mon département
qui faisait face à une facture
d'électricité qui augmentait de 400 % et
qui avait dû fermer la piscine de la
commune on a depuis des quantités
d'autres exemples je pense que réguler
les tarifs que la puissance publique
reprenne la main sur le marché de
l'énergie c'est absolument indispensable
parce que ça ça a des conséquences
concrètes pour les habitants c'est pas
uniquement une question de budget ça
veut dire soit moins de services publics
parce que si les communes doivent faire
face à des augmentations de 3 à 400 %
des coûts énergétiques elles sont
obligées de réduire par ailleurs un
certain nombre de services ça veut dire
moins d'investissement parce qu'elles ne
vont pas pouvoir y compris en termes de
transition énergétique c'est à dire
qu'on a besoin d'investir dans la
sobriété énergétique des bâtiments etc
il faut que les collectivités puissent
le faire qu'elles aient les moyens pour
ça et puis ça peut aussi vouloir dire et
c'est ça qui rend très malheureux
beaucoup d'élus locaux de devoir
augmenter les impôts locaux alors même
que nos concitoyens eux-mêmes font face
à des problématiques de pouvoir d'achat
donc
il y a des solutions
urgentes à prendre on a débattu de
différentes mesures y compris portées
par le gouvernement il était
amortisseur mais il y a aussi des
mesures structurelles parce que les
coûts énergétiques risquent d'être assez
élevé pendant un moment et donc il faut
qu'on puisse agir dans la durée oui
parce que Audrey le texte a été rejeté
mais les sénateurs ils étaient quand
même d'accord sur l'idée générale oui
finalement vous n'étiez pas d'accord sur
la forme sur la solution à apporter mais
sur le fond il y avait pas de débat
c'est vrai que ce soit à droite ou à
gauche de l'hémicycle tout le monde
était d'accord pour dire que vous êtes
au contact des maires et vous le voyez
tous les jours les prix de l'électricité
ont été multipliés par 20 en moins d'un
an vous l'avez dit certains maires
envisagent même de de fermer certains
services municipaux pour maintenir leur
budget à flot vous êtes aussi nombreux à
avoir souligné la difficulté d'accès aux
aides du gouvernement qui ressemble
presque à une
usine à gaz pour certains de vos
collègues on va en écouter justement
l'un de vos collègues c'est Daniel salon
sur la difficulté de ses aides
nous saluons certains des dispositifs
adoptés dans le cadre des récentes lois
de finances je pense à l'amortisseur
électricité l'électricité et à la
reconduction en 2023 du filet de
sécurité même si nous n'avons pas encore
une vision très claire de ces mesures ni
une réelle visibilité sur les
collectivités qui vont être directement
concernés sur le bouclier tarifaire cela
a été dit seul les collectivités de
petites tailles peuvent encore avoir
accès au tarif réglementés de vente au
final nombre de collectivités passeront
à travers ces dispositifs et auront
recours à des offres de marché sur des
contrats d'un à trois ans et seront donc
soumises au prix du marché de l'énergie
lors de l'examen du budget le Sénat
amplifié l'accès à certaines de ces
aides mais votre collègue Fabien gay
s'inquiète qui avec un 49,3 éventuel le
gouvernement revienne sur la
simplification de ces ça vous inquiète
aussi bien sûr
on voit bien qu'on a un mal de chien si
je peux le dire comme ça depuis le début
à faire entendre au gouvernement qui est
un très grave problème pour les
collectivités alors on arrive à
grignoter petit à petit et à obtenir des
mesures petit à petit mais vous avez
raison de dire que ça reste des usines à
gaz sans mauvais jeu de mots très
compliqué pour les collectivités et puis
je le disais dans mon département par
exemple sur 708 communes aujourd'hui il
n'y en a que 99 qui peuvent prétendre
parce qu'en plus on ne sait pas si au
bout du bout elles auront mais
aujourd'hui quelques acomptes voilà et
encore une fois ça ce sont des mesures
d'urgence il y a besoin de mesures
structurelles on ne peut pas laisser
l'énergie qui est un qui est un bien de
première nécessité on le voit ça impacte
la vie de chacun c'est un pack le
développement économique etc dans les
mains du marché et de la spéculation il
faut que la puissance publique reprenne
la main là-dessus pour qu'on régule
régulier peut-être revoir aussi le
marché européen de l'énergie la manière
dont sont fixés les prix des énergies
décorrélés les prix de l'électricité de
ceux du gaz il y a une proposition de
résolution européenne qui est en ce
moment en cours à l'initiative de votre
collègue Franck montogel pour pousser le
gouvernement à agir au niveau européen
vous allez vous y associer alors nous
avons nous-mêmes déposé une proposition
de résolution il y a quelques temps de
ça en ce sens là et évidemment nous nous
associerons à toutes les initiatives qui
seront prises en ce sens avec une
inquiétude c'est que il y a quelques
jours avant-hier si ma mémoire est bonne
au Sénat lors du débat sur les enjeux
européens la ministre a indiqué que ça
ce travail et les éventuels
aboutissements sur le marché européen de
l'énergie ne pourrait pas voir le jour
et se concrétiser avant 2024 c'est dès
cet hiver que se posent les problèmes et
donc il y a urgence à agir et est-ce que
la France se fasse entendre d'une toute
autre manière le l'Espagne le Portugal
ont réussi à obtenir
de s'exonérer des règles du marché
européen pourquoi la France devrait être
le meilleur élève de la classe en quels
sont isolées géographiquement donc il
leur ont donné des il leur ont accordé
c'est nous nous avons aussi des
arguments intervaloirs sur le fait que
notre mix énergétique ne correspond pas
du tout mais alors pas du tout
à la construction des prix tels qu'ils
se font au niveau européen il faut faire
entendre cette voix on ne peut pas
attendre
quel intérêt avons-nous quel intérêt à
la France à être le premier de la classe
des règles européennes alors que des
gens souffrent des collectivités
risquent de ne pas pouvoir boucler leur
budget je crois que il faut vraiment
prendre la mesure de la situation
territoriale entre des collectivités qui
pourront assumer tout ou partie de cette
hausse et celle qui ne pourront pas mais
bien sûr avec pas que par exemple des
des communes qui sont jeunes qui ont
davantage d'écoles par exemple que
d'autres qui doivent donc chauffer
davantage éclairer davantage et
effectivement sans parler du risque de
coupure qui existe qui est inquiète
aussi énormément nos concitoyens en ce
moment et on va en parler justement dans
quelques secondes le temps de remercier
Audrey merci à tout à l'heure Audrey
dans le club on va parler pas
complètement dans notre sujet d'ailleurs
oui finalement des aires du gouvernement
en faveur des collectivités on continue
ce sera tout à l'heure dans le club et
on va justement continuer à parler de
ces questions on va dans votre
département de la Seine-Maritime on
retrouve Thierry rhabiller bonjour
Thierry merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
et d'acteurs en chef à Paris Normandie
et Thierry Bruno Le Maire est attendu à
Polly demain pour une visite sur le site
des nouveaux EPS
et oui exactement donc la question que
je vais adresser à la machine à triste à
essayer une Bruin on est en plein débat
public national depuis la fin octobre ce
débat public doit s'achever fin février
2023 est-ce qu'une pensée pas que cette
visite ministérielle quand même du
ministre de l'économie sur le site qui a
été sélectionné par EDF pour être le
premier site à recevoir les EPR 2 de la
nouvelle génération ne fausse pas
quelque part se débat public on a
l'impression ça peut donner l'impression
que les jeux sont faits et qu'on va tout
droit vers de la construction de
nouveaux générateurs réacteurs
nucléaires en France
je pense qu'on a un problème
effectivement d'ordonnancement si je
peux le dire comme ça de notre politique
énergétique
au point où on en est il aurait fallu
commencer par examiner la programmation
plus réelle de l'énergie et puis ensuite
aborder
l'ensemble des modes de production
énergie renouvelables nucléaire etc etc
aujourd'hui tout ça est saucissonné on a
examiné au Sénat un texte sur les
énergies renouvelables qui est en ce
moment à l'Assemblée on nous parle d'un
texte sur le nucléaire
au début de 2023
et ensuite annuel de l'énergie voilà et
on nous cache ce qu'il y a derrière la
recapitalisation d'EDF qui est en fait
le projet Hercule qui va revenir par la
fenêtre c'est à dire le morcellement et
le démantèlement d'EDF l'outil
énergétique dont on a justement besoin
pour pour assurer la crise que nous
vivons et les trans
si c'est une bonne chose mais à
condition d'en faire un vrai outil
public mais pour répondre à la question
de Thierry rhabiller que je salue
oui il faut qu'on puisse associer les
citoyens à cette discussion je pense que
on voit aujourd'hui que cette question
des politiques énergétiques ça n'est pas
un sujet de spécialiste ça n'est pas un
sujet d'économiste ou d'élus locaux et
qui a besoin de réfléchir à quel mythe
énergétique nous avons moi je suis tout
à fait favorable et je le dis dans le
débat public qui s'engage à l'accueil de
ces epères de nouvelles génération à
panli parce qu'on voit qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans une situation de déficit de
production énergétique mais je tiens
beaucoup et nous l'avons fait entendre
notamment sur les énergies renouvelables
également à ce que les gens soient
associés à ce débat parce qu'il y a rien
de pire que de faire ce type
d'infrastructure que ce soit des
éoliennes ou que ce soit des réacteurs
nu sans en passer par le débat public
les gens veulent de la transparence ils
veulent pouvoir donner leur avis et ça
me semble parfaitement légitime Thierry
une question sur le nucléaire
justement cette voie là que vous portez
vous avec votre groupe avec les autres
élus communistes n'est pas partagé au
sein de la nuque par vos alliés de et
les filles et des verbes bien entendu
est-ce que est-ce que finalement cette
question de l'énergie dans un dans un
dans une situation aujourd'hui très
tendue au niveau de la souveraineté
énergétique de la France est-ce que
c'est un point de crispation qui va nous
faire que s'amplifier et qui va et qui
peut morceler finalement votre votre
groupe la nuque dans les dans les mois à
venir
bon c'est un point de désaccord de
longue date entre certaines forces de
gauche
il y a d'autres points d'accord y
compris en matière énergétique par
exemple sur la nécessité d'un secteur
public d'un service public parce qu'on
voit bien aujourd'hui que laisser faire
le marché et laisser le marché organiser
la politique énergétique nous conduit
dans la situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et qui a besoin là encore
que la puissance publique soit à
l'initiative planifie organise les
choses et une vision de long terme une
politique énergétique ça se fait avec
une vision à 50 ans pas pas sur un
quinquennat évidemment et donc moi je
crois c'est aussi pour cette raison que
je pense qu'il faut associer la
population on voit bien qu'on est dans
une situation qui revisite complètement
ces questions là au sens où je n'avais
pas imaginé et je pense que dans ma
génération et les générations en dessous
n'avait pas imaginé qu'on puisse se
trouver un jour en pénurie d'électricité
en France et bien voilà ça permet de
revisiter le débat de remettre à plat la
manière dont nous produisons de
l'énergie cette pénurie d'électricité
c'est la conséquence du manque
d'investissement sur le nucléaire oui
d'investissement et de renouvellement de
de d'aller vers du nucléaire de
nouvelles générations qui nous oblige à
prolonger la durée de vie des centrales
existantes et qui nous met aujourd'hui
dans la situation qu'on connaît et puis
des sujets pour continuer d'évoquer le
département de la Seine-Maritime
complètement incohérent on ferme la
centrale thermique EDF du Havre il y a
un peu plus d'un an maintenant au motif
et c'est assez juste que le charbon
n'est quand même pas l'énergie la plus
propre qui soit mais pour faire
aujourd'hui un terminal méthanier dans
le port du Havre qui va
liquéfier du gaz naturel
dont une part importante va venir de gaz
de schiste américain
exploiter avec fracturation hydraulique
ce qui est encore pire je dirais en
manière en matière environnementale et
au passage on passe d'un outil public
EDF à un terminal métallier opéré par
Total privé comment nos concitoyens
peuvent-ils comprendre ce type de choix
je crois que vraiment il faut qu'on
renoue avec une politique énergétique de
long terme menée par la puissance
publique étirer une dernière question
sur l'hydrogène verte
oui parce que dans la vallée de la Seine
il y a de nombreux projets qui sont en
train de pousser notamment dans la
région de aux États-Unis originaires en
Seine-Maritime comment vous voyez au
contraire ces investissements qui sont
massifs certains proviennent de grandes
ordres de grands groupes étrangers
canadiens ou américains est-ce que là
aussi vous êtes vous êtes vigilante ou
au contraire vous les accueillez à bras
ouverts ces projets qui sont qui sont
colossaux pour la vallée de la Seine et
pour le département de la Seine-Maritime
en particulier
je pense que tout le monde doit jouer le
jeu du développement de la production
énergétique dans un mix c'est-à-dire
avec différentes effectivement sources
et notamment de l'hydrogène vert et donc
bien sûr que des groupes privés on leur
rôle à jouer et à investir dans la
manière la matière mais il me semble
aussi qu'il faudrait pour pouvoir
organiser et donner de la cohérence et
de la cohésion à l'ensemble de ce
secteur un pôle public
qui permette de chat pot je dirais
l'ensemble de ces productions et donc
oui j'accueille volontiers je pense que
la Normandie a un rôle est une des
premières régions productrices d'énergie
aujourd'hui qu'elle doit le rester
qu'elle doit même
faire des transitions et cela en fait
partie mais oui nous sommes vigilants
parce que nous pensons qu'on ne peut pas
laisser ce secteur uniquement dans les
mains du marché merci Thierry un mot de
sur votre une tout autre sujet l'Armada
je vais être l'encre dans 6 mois on est
toujours sur l'eau mais sur de l'eau
beaucoup plus touristique
merci Thierry ravier merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous depuis la
Seine-Maritime un mot sur un autre sujet
c'est une brûlant c'est les Jeux
Olympiques alors ça peut paraître loin
c'est en 2024 mais quand même vous avez
signé avec une trentaine de sénateurs
une tribune dans Le Monde vous appelez à
tout faire pour sauver les festivals en
2024 menacé justement en raison de
l'organisation de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques Gérald Darmanin a dit
devant le Sénat qu'il était difficile
d'assurer la sécurité de plusieurs
événements d'ampleur simultanés avant de
parler du fond est-ce qu'il y a eu un
problème de forme dans l'annonce de
Gérald Darmanin je ne sais pas si c'est
un problème de forme mais il y a eu
quelque chose d'hallucinant qui s'est
produit effectivement puisque le
ministre de l'Intérieur a annoncé devant
le Sénat
que il faudrait annuler en gros les
festivals que on a vite vu que même la
ministre de la Culture n'avait
absolument pas été associée à cette
annonce
et dont on ne sait d'ailleurs même pas
sur quoi elle se base parce que la
première des choses à faire ce serait
sûrement
de regarder quels sont les besoins en
matière de sécurité pour assurer et les
Jeux Olympiques et les festivals qui
sont tous des moments qui doivent être
des moments festifs des moments de
rassemblement populaire qui vont nous
faire tant de bien dans les périodes
qu'on connaît Chris sanitaire crise
énergétique pouvoir d'achat on a besoin
de rassembler les gens sur des moments
festifs des moments heureux et il y a
rien de pire que de les opposer et enfin
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment très
choquant ce qui s'est passé autour d'eux
et vous le dites dans cette tribune
alors les festivals et finalement ce
sont un moment de rassemblement
populaire mais c'est aussi une manne
économique pour notre territoire comment
on fait du coup pour les sauver en cette
année olympique et ben il faut se mettre
au travail il n'est pas trop tard
regardez quels sont les besoins regarder
si ici ou là il n'y a pas besoin de
modifier un petit peu les dates de
certains festivals
moi je pense que si on met autour de la
table les organisateurs des festivals
les organisateurs djo
les collectivités qui sont elles aussi
beaucoup en soutien de toutes ces
manifestations on va trouver des
solutions intelligentes plutôt que
d'annoncer
enfin moi ça m'a fait l'effet que des
moments qui doivent être heureux
aller se transformer en une concurrence
entre le sport et la culture alors qu'au
contraire tout ça ce sont des grands
moments pour notre pays et qu'il faut
qu'on puisse les réussir tous l'une des
solutions c'est de baisser les ambitions
de la cérémonie d'ouverture on a vu trop
grand pour cette cérémonie d'ouverture
c'est une cérémonie qui se déroulera
tout le long de la scène 600 000
personnes plus de 5 km c'est trop c'est
pas adapté mais je pense que on la
France doit avoir les moyens d'assurer
la sécurité de ce genre d'événements
enfin ça n'est pas possible on parle
depuis un moment du fait que la France
ne va pas être en capacité de de
d'éclairer tous les gens aujourd'hui que
la France ne serait pas en capacité
d'assurer et les Jeux Olympiques et des
festivals non moi je crois qu'on a
d'immenses capacités et qu'il faut les
mobiliser mobiliser l'armée aussi c'est
ce que vous dites aussi dans cette vie
enfin je pense qu'avant ça il y a des
tas d'autres solutions à trouver merci
on aura le temps on aura l'occasion d'en
parler merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure dans le club des
territoires on reviendra sur cette
question des coupures d'électricité de
hausse des prises d'énergie pour les
collectivités elles ont du mal à boucler
leur budget on ira Fontenay aux Roses
voir justement comment fait le maire
mais d'abord on va accueillir notre
prochaine invité c'est Clémentine au
temps qui nous rejoint